hey everyone this is all asunder and I
am here with Ronnie Hobbs the creative
director at Gunn media and we're here to
play layers of fear - how's it going man
good it's awesome it's awesome to be
here so yeah thanks for letting me stop
by and show you the game yeah cool this
is obviously the sequel to layers of
fear which is a something of a is a
sleeper hit you know it just sort of
came out of nowhere and like it really
scared a lot of people so must be pretty
exciting to sort of get the sequel out
as opposed to the original game which
focused more on like a sort of an
aspiring artist you're now an actor in
this game that is correct so yeah like
you said part one was heavily inspired
by art this one inspired by film so you
play an actor who's been invited to take
part in a movie by a very eccentric
director of course played by Tony Todd
Candyman so you hear his voice a lot
little sparks
as soon as you board the ship
unfortunately your past trauma and loss
start to take over so as you're trying
to struggle to prepare for this role you
slowly start to descend into madness and
it's not the player to figure out what
these memories are what's going on is
this real is it not so that's really
where we're at right now and kind of the
basis for about what you're about to see
[Music]
distraction we have three endings and
the game by the way so based on
decisions that you make you'll get one
of three Indians one of these decisions
I'm about to show you right now
[Music]
[Music]
that'll do for now the main cabin that
you start and you'll revisit that after
each chapter and that's where you'll
find your collectibles similar to layers
of fair one yeah so it must be pretty
challenging trying to sort of like make
a sequel to a horror game because in a
lot of ways like I think fans sort of
like can get a sense of what the type of
experience will be and in some ways that
could sort of maybe lessen the scare so
you talked a little bit about you know
sort of what's how you want to approach
like you know things differently with
this game right away we should tell you
that this is not a you know the stories
aren't linked you know you don't have to
enjoy the first game to to understand
this one if you have played the first
one there's a lot of lower elements and
Easter eggs that carry over but other
than that it's a completely separate
world completely separate story I think
a lot of the reason why we why Bluebird
chose a cruise ship it's because it is
so different than like a house which
would have been the easy thing to do
just move to another mansion and play
with the new character so by taking it
boarded like this ocean liner we have
this combination of tight confines and
outside area too which is kind of open
so it's a nice mixture and so yeah it's
about just making it bigger and better
you know on your second time around and
that is a challenge because people tend
to expect that they learn your tricks
you know Bluebird is really really great
at the ever-changing environment which
is you turn around something's not there
you turn around and it's back again and
you're about to see some of that really
this the whole team has tried to take
that up a notch
[Music]
the there's a lot of nods to classic
films in this game where as part of
mozart this one's film so everything
from Wizard of Oz to Nasser ah to to
Suspiria to Dogville yeah we feature
some of the Suspiria nods and the PAX
East so big big big film and nerds
everyone working on this game so there's
a lot of classic film references here
and blue-ber did such an outstanding job
of taking what they loved about those
films and then seamlessly put them into
the story yeah you know so you'll
probably see a few more she doesn't like
it when you play with anyone but her
that's a story I was a fine they give
you subtle clues and hits and I said
also say that the director Tony Todd is
like ever watching and always present
and always judging your performance so
to speak so he's a pretty main character
in this game and one that you won't know
a lot about
so that's our first thing we're gonna
look at today and that was the formless
man so that's the homeless man homeless
man this the main antagonist in the game
a lot of running and hiding and
definitely he'll definitely be pursuing
you and even kill you at times if you're
not careful so so we're now jumping
ahead to the next area of the game
called the kitchen this is a obviously
vastly different than a cruise ship the
strangest you like I said this is just
one of the different environments that I
know people assume that layers of here
too is just layers of here one on a
cruise ship and that is not the case it
also accept you to once again figure out
these memories and see if you can figure
out this classic film nod that we're
about to take part in
[Music]
[Music]
again just like it's such a challenge
making a horse a good horror sequel so a
lot always you have to examine what made
the original good but also try to expand
upon that in in the bigger way yeah so
you know it's not there's always a fine
line between too many jump scares or not
enough jump scares or maybe an
antagonist that it's too powerful or not
as powerful as you expect you always
have to keep players on edge and
thankfully Bluebird is incredible with
that and there's a lot of tension and a
lot of dread that's built up throughout
some of these scenes that we haven't
shown yet and the visual style - I think
goes a long way there's nothing like
this visually on the market in my
opinion even the story I mean there's a
lot of great stories out there like you
eat it Finch and I could go on and on
but this is one of those stories that I
had to read the script about 35 times
Wow
I mean it's a lot a lot of reading on
the script and and then it can it didn't
clicks and you're like oh okay so
there's a lot of hidden hidden meaning
and undertones so we're jumping ahead
one more time to see one of the later
sections of the game called the bedroom
which is a seems to be way more creepy
than the last one which was which is
saying a lot yes yes so this is a
obviously very very unique house as you
can tell by the architecture once again
pulled from classical film love there's
nothing a lot of characters involved in
the scene who which you don't know who
they are yet and you won't know until
maybe the very end
it's one of those type of stories where
there's probably gonna be no direct
answers provided you're gonna have to
replay and replay it or go online and
talk to other people and figure out like
there's not a lot of hand-holding here
so that's one of the things that
believer loved about their stories and
and again this has multiple endings so a
choice you made may a benign choice
actually that at the beginning may you
know have some severe consequences like
yes yeah so this is also a very puzzle
heavy room so that's why we wanted to
show this to you guys today it's super
unnerving seeing all these sort of NPCs
in character yeah you are always bad
luck a blight upon this family I give
everything a lucky break and ice up my
sleeve that's all I need
as you might have guessed the story is
very very heavy and very very emotional
times and I feel like this game seems to
put you in a greater sense of confusion
constantly like second-guessing
everything you see I would say that's
correct
yeah even yeah it's taken what Bluebird
had done with layers fair one and
probably you know increased it double
yeah it's there's a lot of confusion and
subverting expectations yes yep I told
you to keep it safe how could you let
him take it
it's all we have left of her you have to
find it you have to take it back
keep her close to your heart don't let
her be forgotten she gave everything for
you prove that it was worth it that you
want a mistake give him back his ace
there we go uprooted by tragedy
excuse me
that's all you've ever given me that's
so do you so like works we're excited it
comes out May 28th yeah yeah it's fast
approaching or so pretty quick episode
so it's on Steam it's on Xbox one and
ps4 thanks again mr. Hobbes for dropping
by yeah thanks for having us so thank
you and that was layers of fear too